tonight has been an amazing night for
the both of us yes it has getting to
perform on stage at radio city
meeting janet jackson eminem
anyway
this is fun two words come to mind life
insurance yes
girls girls just a reminder it's not how
big the banana is it's how you sit on it
what i'm sitting on a banana come on uh
what was this award for i'm sorry
huh
[Music]
oh viewers choice oh my god y'all thank
you
and the golden globe goes too you want
to open it you want me to do it yeah i
have the nails yeah get after it
you got the globes too um
billy bob forden fargo
ricky gervais couldn't be here tonight
so instead we're going to give this to
our friend steve carell
[Applause]
look at his stupid face
couldn't actually win one of his own so
he stole someone else's
i also personally owe judd a lot he and
director paul fee gave me my first ever
job in america in their smash hit
bridesmaids
before that i was just a street girl he
sometimes did crack
our gymnastics team was so dominant that
kevin durant told me he wants to play
for them next year
and i just want to say this movie was a
life-changing experience i saw some
amazing beautiful invigorating parts of
america but i saw
some dark parts of america
an ugly side of america a side of
america that rarely sees the light of
day
i refer of course to the anus and
testicles of my co-star ken division
[Applause]
and secondly and even more important is
your whole career as a comedian is about
making fun of pretentious high-minded
self-congratulatory bs events like this
one
the whole feeling in this room of
reverence and honoring
is the exact opposite of everything i
have wanted my life to be about
i i really don't want to be up here
i want to be in the back over there
somewhere over there saying something
funny to somebody about what a croc this
whole thing is
we're uh we're here tonight to present
the award for outstanding supporting
actor and actress in a comedy series we
used to submit ourselves in this
category but it didn't work out too well
for us
not none of us ever won
well
i i won
[Applause]
yeah
for
seriously for our show or
yeah
well
how come you never told us
i i i guess i i just wanted to avoid
something awkward
like right now oh you know it's funny
because i i saw that emmy statue of your
house but i figured you just ripped it
off from some of the frasier people
i have never been invited to the oscars
because
as you know they are racists
but the baftas have diverse members
and that's what we all want to see in
life isn't it
diverse members
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominations for best actor and
supporting role are
that run on just threw me there
should be an olympic event shouldn't it
he could strap we hurdles to people and
get let me do that
i would turn up hey
that was very pleasant i must say
jeez we should do that motor much much
more often
no
and what a nice dress
and really attractive men have been
nominated
and i really look forward to
congratulating the winner
although i'm looking forward even more
to consoling the four losers
and um shout out to donatella versace
for custom making this outfit for me and
shout out and shout out to michael b
jordan because he's going to be taking
it off of me tonight
and then there was all the talk about
how kobe
needs shaq to win a championship i mean
me personally i couldn't help but notice
how the boston celtics didn't need
either of you
here are the nominees
for argo ben affleck
for zero dark 30 catherine bigelow
and for django unchained quentin
tarantino
and the golden globe goes to
[Applause]
ben affleck argo
i want to thank my co-stars
leo
margot robbie margot robbie's feet
margaret crowley's feet dakota fannick's
feet
seriously quentin has separated more
women from their shoes than the tsa
hello there
thank you for having me back it's such a
pleasure to be here last year was the
best night of my husband's life
he he actually says that and i've given
birth three times
i guess this is the closest i'll get to
george clooney i'm gonna repeat that
rihanna was kicked off instagram
for excessive
nudity what the [ __ ] listen
rihanna being banned from instagram is
like banning a waffle house
from from basically having videos on
world star hip hop it would be a stupid
sight tell you something else she's so
sexy that i would honestly pay a million
dollars to see her naked here's the
thing i've already seen it and i'm
willing to pay again
i would i would still pay for it how
many men are mad that she didn't come
naked
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know if i'd be standing here
today if it wasn't for my shop teacher
mr no fingers
two big thumbs up to you buddy
and an extra
special tip of the hat to my art teacher
miss never wore a bra
you my lady made learning fun again
but jack say it more buddha because
you've got you dressed up tonight and
wearing the sunglasses inside works
[Applause]
first i'd like to thank um did you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
eddie pull it up like oh the working
forms
and i started to do it too yes mike wait
what am i doing
i am george clooney this is mark
wahlberg
we are uh here to present the award for
best uh villain
come on come here no no come on you're
in the middle you're in the middle just
get a little hit of clooney okay
i think we'll go right to the nominees
it doesn't get any better than that
really i would also like to thank my
wife nancy for giving me two wonderful
children as painful as her labor might
have been
thanks also to an excellent cast crew
and writing staff all of whom i am
indebted to if it were not for you i
would not be here right now i don't know
about that
steve sauer michelle bowen matt labov
holly burrell
nancy my precious wife
who put her career on hold in support of
mine
and who sometimes wishes that i would
let her know when i'm going to be home
late so she can schedule her life which
is no less important than mine
to my parents for not making me go to
law school
and finally to the love of my life
my wife nancy thank you very much great
honor